montag aktien dabei 2020 in österreich
starten die ersten miliz einsätze im
niederösterreichischen mistelbach
übergibt verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner das kommando unsere heutige tag
an dem diese übernehmen ihre aufgaben im
interesse der sicherheit österreichs die
das österreichische promotion die
soldatinnen und soldaten wurden noch nie
so sehr gebraucht wie das jetzt der fall
ist und eine durchhaltefähigkeit zu
garantieren wäre ohne die heutige
übernahme der milizsoldaten ohne zweifel
nicht möglich das muss um die
herauslösung aus dem assistenzeinsatz
punkte übergabe
durch die übergabe der einsatz schleife
wird die kommandoübergabe vollzogen
[Musik]